American country and southern gospel
singer and songwriter Larry Gatlin who
knew the king of rock and roll and
Lisa's father Elvis joins me now Larry
this is so sad to have heard this in
your reaction tonight
well hello Lawrence good to see you I
wish you were under different
circumstances you know I was shocked uh
at 74 years old I think I probably think
uh in these days in which I live a
little bit more about death uh but then
I did when I was 54 or 34 or 24. we were
told those some Christian people say
well you're not supposed to question God
uh I think that's Malarkey we wouldn't
be human beings if we didn't question
when things happen to young people like
Lisa Marie or to the young man who
almost died the other day but thanks for
the grace of God the paramedics brought
to the young football player back to
life so I'm very saddened by it uh their
family has you know so much tragedy in
that family and uh you know you know my
one of my cousins believe it or not John
Doan who wrote no man is denial and unto
himself we are all part of civilization
and when any person dies it affects me
because I am part of the main I am part
of civilization part of humanity so when
our fellow our fellow man tragedy
strikes like this obviously it breaks
our hearts it really does well Elvis
yeah as everything I've read and the
biographies of Elvis that I've been able
to read uh over the last 25 years
um you know he loved his daughter so
much
um and his only child and she had to
obviously understand her father's drug
use her son struggled with addiction and
committed suicide uh was well documented
uh her own stents in rehab and struggles
with cocaine and Other Drugs we have no
idea what the cause of death was
Ultimate cause of death other than
Cardiac Arrest what caused the cardiac
arrest but this is really just a series
and obviously Michael Jackson uh dying
after the use of propofol so this is a
series of
uh tragic tragic events
well it really is you know I've been in
Nashville Janice and I've lived in
Nashville on and off for the last 50
years and we have seen time and time
again the the children of famous people
seem to have a a tough road to go and uh
but but all of us who Among Us you know
those people out there right now trying
to uh
you know buy bread buy milk buy diapers
for their kids uh we are we're kind of
in a jam as a world and as a country so
it is time for us to to kind of circle
around and hug each other and pray for
each other nothing we can say uh will
really make them feel any better but we
say it anyway because our hearts have
compassion for these folks uh I knew
Lisa Marie a little bit in fact I I
babysat with her many many years ago
Believe It or Not uh when her mom was
good friends with carlanna mascale
friend of ours and we were in Vegas and
uh she was just a baby just an infant so
the few times I met her she came on the
Grand Ole Opry a couple times she was
very sweet uh I loved and respected her
father I think it's one of the tragic uh
well it's Flex say it's tragic when
anyone passes away but especially uh in
the prime of life so uh the gatlins uh
are praying for all the Presleys and uh
and wishing that God's uh peace and
comfort comes with them I think you're
right the town all it's so many talented
musicians I mean and obviously they're
famous people you know Michael Jackson
Prince uh obviously uh you know we don't
know what happened in this case but
they're just so many Jim Morrison I mean
over the years I mean so many have
passed away uh Whitney Houston You know
the list goes on and on of people with
just enormous Talent
well you know Laura a lot of times it's
hard for people to tell us no
you know how do you tell Elvis Presley
to stop doing it people told me to stop
doing it and by the grace of a merciful
god when Janice and Coach Darrell Royal
uh came to me and said you have to stop
acting like that uh it's in
McConaughey's book on page 157 I think
uh my little story with Coach Royal but
it's hard for people no you can't do
that
it's hard to do that uh but thank God
for those people who do and for you
folks out there and ready on TV Land if
you have somebody in your life who's
having trouble with that uh go go take a
hold of them by the nape of the neck and
by the heart and tell them they're they
need to do something about it so I'm
grateful to God that Daryl and Janice
did it for me uh Larry thank you for
your remembrances uh tonight and we
really really appreciate it thank you
Larry Gatlin hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else